with all these chicks just stuck in
their house sitting there bored
completely in love with me and of course
they don't go out they're not allowed
out social media star Andrew Tate is
already under investigation for sex
crimes in Romania now he's facing legal
action in the UK
three women are planning to sue him for
damages for personal injury and
psychiatric harm
one said to have seen Andrew Tate's rise
in popularity and influence while
knowing who he is and what he has done
has been extremely difficult for those
of us who were sexually and physically
abused by him we intend to prove in
court that Andrew is abusive coercive
and controlling
their lawyer listed the women's
allegations rape
sexual and physical assaults including
holding guns to women's heads
strangulations
beatings with belts awful awful
allegations of the most awful Behavior
towards women
the women's allegations were reported to
police eight years ago Tate was arrested
on suspicion of rape but never charged
Hertfordshire police investigated what
they described as a complex and
challenging case after discussions with
the crown prosecution service they
closed it four years later and
apologized for delays
in a statement the CPS said in this case
we carefully reviewed all the evidence
provided by the police regarding each
complainant and concluded it did not
meet our legal test and there was no
realistic Prospect of a conviction
Hertfordshire police said officers from
the team who dealt with this case are
available to meet with the women
involved to speak to them about their
concerns and the investigation we're
aware of the evidence that was provided
and produced it should have been
sufficient to Warrant a proper criminal
investigation and in our opinion for
charges to have been brought and if
those charges had been brought and he'd
been arrested here in England then
perhaps he wouldn't have fled to Romania
where he is reported to have committed
further terrible crimes against women
Tate spokesman said he vehemently denied
the UK and Romanian allegations and he
had not been warned of the planned civil
action Marty brunt Sky News